top on sait que j'existe maison ne sais
pas où je me trouve
l'atlantide exhale des diplômes ligonnès
on sait que j'existe mais on ne sait pas
vraiment à quoi je sers le conseil de
sécurité de l'onu nicolas dupont aignan
pour ne cite jamais mon obole de mort
voldemort
on sait que j'existe mais on ne parle
pas de moi dans les livres d'école je
suis je suis le bouton rice
ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais
ouais
[Musique]
on en parle ni dans les manuels
scolaires ni dans les dix ce qui
explique le corps humain aux enfants et
à vrai dire on n'en parle pas beaucoup
aux adultes
thouars morts c'est ce que c'est le
clitoris ben non sérieux j'ai pas fais
latin au collège mains ok mais qu'est ce
qu'il a bien pu faire le clitoris pour
mériter au mieux une telle indifférence
au pire un tel mépris
bon on va en parler un peu plus tard
mais commençons par le début sinon on va
me reprocher de faire des titres puis
taklit alors le clitoris c'est quoi ces
housses que je vous propose c'est une
petite visite guidée et bas un clitoris
c'est ça enfin c'est par là on va jouer
à où est charlie
alors vous l'avez ici non ça c'est le
trou du caca et l'anus par là non plus
ça c'est le vagin là non là non plus ça
c'est le méat urinaire c'est le trou du
pipi alors par là non ça c'est jul sais
pas ce qu'il faut là non le clitoris
il se trouve ici tout en haut de la
bulle
enfin là c'est juste qu'on voit de
l'extérieur c'est-à-dire le capuchon
qu'on appelle en réalité le prépuce est
un petit repli tout qui recouvre l'autre
partie externe du clitoris le fameux
petit bouton qui s'appelle en réalité
lui le gland et ouais c'est la même
structure et les mêmes mots pour les
deux sexes
d'ailleurs avant la douzième semaine de
grossesse tout le monde a le même
tubercules génitales ce n'est qu'après
qu'ils se développent en organes
masculins ou en organes féminins
c'est pour ça qu'avant on ne peut pas
déterminer le sexe du bébé à
l'échographie
bref la partie externe du clitoris se
situe tout en haut de la vulve donc
juste au dessus d'une
l'inner sa taille et sa forme varie
d'une personne à l'autre comme plein
d'autres organes genre les oreilles le
nez etc
mais ça ça n'est que la partie émergée
de l'iceberg ne faisons pas durer le
suspense plus longtemps en réalité un
clitoris
ça ressemble à ça hop là voilà un
clitoris c'est tout ça l'organe complet
mesures une bonne dizaine de centimètres
donc là tout en hausse et le blanc donc
mais tout le reste est à l'intérieur
le coût de la juste après de blanc et
ben réalité c'est pas un coude ça
s'appelle le genou ne demandez pas
pourquoi les deux grands trucs là qui
ressemble à l'os du poulet pour faire un
voeu ce sont les racines ou pilier du
clitoris
ce sont des corps caverneux et les deux
bulles de la juste en dessous ce sont
des corps spongieux qui sont placés de
chaque côté du conduit du vagin avec
l'excitation sexuelle l'ensemble se
gorgent de sang ce qui provoque une
érection aussi bien à l'intérieur qu'à
l'extérieur et qu'il fait à l'intérieur
se voit à l'extérieur
le clitoris est extrêmement énervé
beaucoup plus que le vagin est beaucoup
plus que le pénis mais bon ça c'est pas
le sujet du jeu c'est donc un organe
très sensible et très réactif et c'est
surtout la porte d'entrée numéro un
verts l'orgasme pour celles qui ont la
chance de pouvoir en avoir
ce qui n'est malheureusement pas le cas
de tout le monde l'orgasme peut être
atteint par stimulation directe de la
partie externe
vous voyez à peu près comment on fait
mais aussi par stimulation indirecte des
parties internes pendant la pénétration
vaginale alors avant que vous posiez la
question non le clitoris et le point g
c'est pas la même chose et ça on en
reparlera dans une prochaine vidéo
enfin si ça vous intéresse je ne sais
pas dites moi dans les commentaires bon
mais alors c'est quoi le problème avec
le clitoris
pourquoi on le connaît si mal le
problème du clitoris est sans doute
pourtant ce qui fait sa force c'est le
seul organe dont la seule fonction est
le
plaisir et le plaisir c'est sale
apparemment d'ailleurs vous savez comme
on appelle le nerf qui innerve mes
organes génitaux le nerf ou tout
pourtant c'est plutôt sympa le plaisir
non je veux dire ça fait plaisir
et du coup c'est quoi le problème
pourquoi personne parle du clitoris est
pas important de plaisir ça sert à rien
ben ça sert à quoi
bonne question d'abord le clitoris est
le meilleur ami des préliminaires qui
sont eux mêmes les meilleurs potes d'un
rapport sexuel harmonieux donc c'est
important
bon mais pour l'utilité du plaisir en
tant que tel disons que manifestement
quand on a été conçu
l'ingénieur s'est demandé comment nous
inciter à satisfaire nos besoins vitaux
pour tout ce qui se passe à l'intérieur
de notre corps comme la respiration la
fonction cardiaque et plein d'autres
fonctions vitales ingénieur il s'est pas
fait chier il a tout mis sur pilote
automatique il a tout relié au système
nerveux autonome qui gère tout ça sans
qu'on ait eu le temps de s'en occuper
il est en tout ce qui nécessite une
action volontaire extérieur au corps il
a fallu trouver un autre créé un besoin
bien sûr le désir en l'occurrence mais
apparemment ça suffisait pas c'est à ce
moment là que le plaisir a été mis au
point pour récompenser la satisfaction
d'un besoin vital c'est à dire un de
ceux qui sont indispensables à notre
survie ou à celle de notre espèce jean
roy remanger copuler ça fonctionne
notamment grâce à des substances comme
la dopamine où les endorphines dont on a
déjà parlé respectivement dans les
vidéos sur le cannabis et la
masturbation l'amour là on parle de la
v11 depuis on a pas mal été au gré des
et disons qu'on n'utilise plus le
plaisir sexuel uniquement pour la
reproduction et s'il y en a qui disent
que c'est mal demandez leur ce qu'ils
boivent est ce qu'ils mangent comme ça
juste pour voir
il se trouve que ce qui caractérise
l'humanité et qui la différencie du
reste du monde animal c'est de faire des
choses qui ne sont pas absolument
indispensable à la survie ce qui les
empêche pas d'être indispensable à la
vie tout court 1 en tout cas à
l'épanouissement personnel
rires par exemple ça sert à rien la
musique et toutes les autres formes
d'art pareil se faire du bien de manière
générale biologiquement parlant on peut
survivre sans donc
vivre sans on est d'accord voilà donc le
plaisir c'est du sérieux bon on va pas
se voiler la face l'autre problème du
clitoris c'est que c'est l'organe du
plaisir féminin donc le plaisir féminin
il a longtemps été au mieux il y aurait
au pire diaboliser c'est la raison pour
laquelle on se retrouve avec un certain
nombre de femmes qui connaissent mal
leur corps et je n'arrive même pas des
hommes et c'est aussi la raison pour
laquelle dans une tout autre mesure
aujourd'hui encore on parle de 200
millions de femmes excisées dans le
monde avec chaque année trois millions
de jeunes filles qui subissent cette
mutilation génitale qui consiste à
retirer le clitoris et les petites
lèvres voir les grandes lèvres juste à
cause de cette idée que le plaisir
féminin c'est mal une campagne de lutte
contre l'excision a été lancé par une
association dont vous trouverez le lien
dans la description de cette vidéo
parce que oui ça existe aux filles en
europe et même en france
avant de se quitter retenu une chose que
vous soyez une femme ou un homme
apprendre à mieux connaître le clitoris
ça ne peut être que bénéfique
voilà dtc c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on
se retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle
vidéo d'ici là apprenez à vous connaître
et à connaître les autres
respectez vous et à respecter les autres
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]